try them out we'll show the Biden
Administration tried and failed to throw
a father of seven in prison for 11 years
for the crime of being a pro-life
activist the ruling regime is vengeful
and Petty and will do everything in its
power to destroy anyone who fails to
submit we'll talk about that also more
States across the country are moving to
ban the mutilation and castration of
children we'll discuss how the
anti-gender ideology movement managed to
have so much success in such a short
amount of time and the Surgeon General
warns about the dangers of social media
for children he's right about that but
his concern for the safety of children
seems to be rather selective plus I
scandalized a feminist during a panel
segment on Piers Morgan show when I
suggested that women should maybe wear
clothing when they go out in public
we'll talk about that provocative
opinion and much more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you know it's tough to stick to your New
Year's resolutions but here's one that
you can accomplish today you can
complete your will with epic will that's
for just 119 in as little as five
minutes epic will can help you create
your last will and testament your living
will and even your health care power of
attorney their step-by-step online form
makes it incredibly easy all you need to
do is fill in the blanks fifty percent
of Americans don't have a will well you
could choose today to be in the smarter
half and get that will done by going to
epicworld.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Wheels complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Welsh
well in September of this past year
early one Friday morning dozens of armed
federal agents descended on the home of
a wanted fugitive this is a man accused
of violating federal law and who said
the federal government deserves to spend
over a decade in prison that man was
named Mark helk despite appearances he
was not actually some sort of terrorist
or drug trafficker or child predator we
could already assume that he was none of
those things because if he was he never
would have attracted the FBI's interest
in the first place instead he was along
with being a law-abiding father of seven
a pro-life activist how stood accused of
violating the freedom of access to
Clinic entrances or face act and
supposedly he had done something to
prevent people from accessing an
abortion clinic which is a violation of
federal law now although strangely
enough the incident in question had
occurred a year prior in 2021 in the
local D.A in Philadelphia who's hardly a
right-wing Zealot had already looked at
the case and decided that no charges
were warranted a year after that
the Biden Administration gave it another
look and decided that not only had a
crime occurred but that the alleged
criminal was so dangerous and so
Sinister that he deserved to be frog
marched outside of his home at the break
of dawn and if they could prove their
case in a court of law thrown in federal
prison for 11 years
but as it happens they could not prove
their case in federal court on Monday at
the conclusion of a week-long trial halc
was acquitted by a jury that was not
convinced that he was the dastardly
militant that Biden's goons tried to
make him out to be judge Gerald um
papard seemed to Echo the jury's
concerns when he asked during the trial
he asked the prosecutor in the case
whether the law that halc was being
tried under was perhaps he said being
quote stretched a little thin
stretched a little thin indeed as it
turns out Hulk was not blocking anyone
from entering a clinic now if he had
been he of course still wouldn't deserve
a decade in federal lock-up uh I mean if
it were up to me and he was actually
blocking people from entering a clinic
then I would give him the medal of
freedom for his efforts but but even by
the already deranged standards of the
face act the law written and passed
by politicians who were purchased and
paid for by the abortion industry even
by those standards this prosecution was
unjust
in fact there is video of the
altercation that led to houck's arrest
video that was just made public this
week Sean Hannity played the tape on a
show a few days ago and um here it is
now for this altercation with a if you
take a look with a Planned Parenthood
escort now as you can see in your upper
left-hand Corner Mark accompanied by his
son standing away from the entrance to
the clinic when he is approached by the
escort identified as Bruce love who
repeatedly try to antagonize Houck
allegedly verbally harassing him and his
son before Houck eventually shoves him
after multiple attempts to Defuse The
Situation the Planned Parenthood manual
clearly states that escorts are not to
antagonize or even engage with any
protesters a rule let love clearly broke
so there it is that's why Biden wanted
to lock a father of seven in prison for
a decade for that because he shoved a
guy Hulk standing far away from the
entrance to any Clinic he was standing
on the on the street corner where he has
every right to be
uh and while he was standing there he
shoved the clinic asked Gordon Halk says
that he was um
you know lashing out because the escort
was harassing him and his teenage son in
San crude and disgusting things now the
escort says that that isn't true
and you can decide whether you believe
Hulk or whether you believe the sort of
man who volunteers his time to escort
pregnant women into a building so they
can have their babies butchered
I know who I trust
but it doesn't make much of a difference
anyway whatever the reason for the push
A push is all it was
it's hard to imagine a push that could
warrant the involvement of 25 FBI agents
and felony charges carrying a decade in
prison
but if such a push exists that one
certainly wasn't it
and one can't help but note the irony
here I mean we spent
much of the past week responding to the
bleeding heart types who were coil and
horror and Shout cruel and unusual
punishment if you Advocate harsher
penalties for violent criminals and
carjackers and Drug kingpins
these types they'll always show up
pocket constitutions in hand solemnly
citing the Eighth Amendment if you dare
suggest that we should go a little tough
on the types of criminals who have made
countless communities across the country
basically unlivable
but how quickly does their compassion
run out when the criminal in question is
a pro-life activist
in this case they have no problem in
fact are strongly in favor of giving him
a tougher sentence than the courts
usually give to rapists and armed
robbers
I mean that's no surprise after all
these are the same people who scream
about police brutality but then sheared
when Capitol police shot an unarmed
woman for the for the crime of you know
trespassing
so what was this all really about then
why was Biden determined to rip this man
away from his children destroy his
family confine him to a cage for the
next 11 years of his life why was he so
determined to do that well for the
obvious reasons
they wanted to ruin him because he dared
to act according to beliefs
that the ruling regime abhors
and they wanted to ruin him because they
could or they thought they could
he was meant to be an example a warning
signal ahead on a pike at the edge of
town an ominous sign for those who come
after him
a tried and true strategy on the left
and you can just ask Jack Phillips if
you want to know more about that before
Mark Houck had become the Al Capone of
the modern era for getting into a brief
shoving match with a creep outside of an
abortion clinic Jack Phillips had long
since begun his own Reign of Terror
now Phillips if you if you see him he
may he may look unassuming and
non-threatening but beneath that Placid
exterior lies the dark heart of a super
villain who wants viciously traumatized
the gay couple by declining to make a
customized cake for their wedding
but that's not the only cake he didn't
want to make Fox News has the latest
quote a Colorado Baker who won a partial
U.S Supreme Court victory in a case
where he refused to make a cake for a
gay wedding lost an appeal in another
legal fight in which he rejected a
request for a birthday cake celebrating
a gender transition the Colorado Court
of Appeals ruled on Thursday that the
refusal by Jack Phillips and masterpiece
cake shop to make a cake requested by
Autumn scardina did not constitute Free
Speech the court also found it was
illegal to refuse to provide services to
People based on characteristics like
race religion or sexual orientation
quote we conclude that creating a pink
cake with blue frosting is not
inherently expressive and any message or
symbolism it provides to an observer
would not be attributed to the baker
said the court which also rejected
procedural arguments from Phillips the
Cake Shop initially agreed to um
make the cake but then refused after
scardina explained that it was going to
be used to celebrate her
her that's a
Fox News using the the her there
transition from male to female the court
found Philip said the cake that he makes
are um are a form of free speech and
plans to appeal the ruling quote one
need not agree with Jack's view to agree
that all Americans should be free to say
what they believe even if they even if
the government disagrees with those
beliefs according to Jake Warner senior
Council for Alliance defending Freedom
who represented Phillips John McHugh one
of the lawyers who represented scardina
said that Phillips objected to making
the cake because he objected quote to
the idea of Miss Gardena wanting a
birthday cake that reflects her status
as a transgender woman
because they object to the existence of
transgender people
Okay so
it has been 10 years since Phillips
gently declined the request to customize
a cake for a gay wedding that's an
important point he didn't refuse to bake
a cake
for the gay couple you never refused
service to gay people he never said I
won't make you a cake
what he says it what he said is I can't
specifically customize this cake for the
purpose of this gay wedding
10 years since that a decade the amount
of time that Biden wanted Mark Houck to
spend in prison an LGBT activist has
spent all that time trying to destroy
him destroy a small town cake maker for
refusing to bend the knee and submit
they have spent 10 years targeting them
that's how vengeful and Petty they are
10 years trying to exact their revenge
for a cake
and that's all that this gender
transition cake was about Mr scardina is
a trans activist to engage in a not at
all subtle attempt to entrap Phillips by
asking him to make a pink cake with blue
ice icing something that again
he would have done okay if scardina had
just gone to Phillips and said oh I want
to uh I want a cake I want it to have a
blue icing and I want it to be a pink
cake
if he had done that
Jack Phillips would have said sure here
you go here's your cake no problem
okay Phillips wasn't asking what's this
cake going to be used for huh tell me
you know fill out this disclosure form
to tell us all the purposes that this
cake will be will be used for that never
happened
Philip said sure we'll make the cake
and then uh
scardina made a point of explaining oh
by the way this is going to be used in a
gender transition celebration what do
you think about that huh
there was no reason to tell Phillips
that
there was also no reason to throw this
celebration especially because scardina
certainly has no friends to invite to
the party anyway but scardina targeted
Phillips tried to back him into a corner
all so that he could do exactly what he
has done spend years in court suing him
for his refusal
that's how ruthless and soulless and
downright trifling these people are
that's how determined they are to make
you submit
both Mark howk and Jack Phillips are
meant to be a warning to all of us
you know what instead they should be an
inspiration
because they show us what happens if you
don't surrender but they also show us
that you don't have to surrender
and you shouldn't
now let's get to our headlines
if one of your goals this year is to do
business with companies who share your
values that's a great goal to have then
check out Pure Talk Pure Talk is the
antidote to woke wireless companies it's
proudly veteran owned employs a us-based
customer service team and absolutely
refuses to spend money on fake news
networks not to mention Pure Talk
service is fantastic they're one of the
largest networks in the country you can
get blazing fast data also talk and text
for as low as 30 a month is probably
half of what you're paying Verizon at T
or T-Mobile all you gotta do is switch
over to Pure Talk in as little as 10
minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone numbers well your first month
is guaranteed risk-free you can try it
and if you're not completely happy with
your service you'll get your money back
but I think that you will be happy this
year make it a goal to support companies
that support you go to puretalk.com
enterpromocode Walsh to say 50 off your
first month that's puretalk.com promo
code Walsh Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
all right by the way uh my apologies for
missing the show yesterday I I think a
pretty good excuse I didn't film the
show because at the time when we would
film it I had been sitting in the
hospital with our two-week-old baby for
uh at that point about 10 hours or so uh
at like midnight on on Monday night I
took one of the twins to the emergency
room because he was having kind of a
labored breathing and erratic breathing
and he'd also stopped eating which is
very very bad signs for an infant on
both counts uh there's a cold basically
has been going through our house really
mild for the rest of us but for
undersized preemie newborns a cold can
be you know potentially quite
catastrophic so he made the mistake the
decision that I would take him actually
my wife wanted to take him but
to make matters more interesting there
was supposed to be an ice storm that was
uh going to be hitting us that night and
I wasn't going to send my you know two
weeks postpartum wife and my newborn son
out into an ice storm so so of course I
I took the the child and to get to the
end of the story everything's fine uh
the baby's fine they monitored his
breathing for what ended up being like
16 hours and he's okay scary moments
there at first but everything uh thank
God everyone is fine
actually the baby's doing better than I
am at this point because
um after I pulled it an all-nighter it's
like that's the kind of thing as a
younger man yeah I can remember being
younger and there were times when I
would stay up all night never for a
selfless reason like taking care of a
baby but then the next day you know
you're okay just you kind of function
and as you get older it's just that you
have to pay one all-nighter you're gonna
pay for that for the next two and a half
months pretty much although I will say
while I was sitting in the uh in the
triage area of the hospital the the
nurses came in
and they said you know if you
yeah we could bring in a cot so you can
sleep
and I'm thinking is that do parents
usually do that you've got to you bring
your child in who can't breathe
and you come in to deal with a child and
the the father's like taking a nap in
the corner of the room
I don't know
um and by the way those ice storms two
of them there were supposed to be
especially one on Monday night uh when
we took the baby to the hospital and
then last night there was supposed to be
another one and both of them ended up
being total Duds I mean a little bit of
freezing rain uh but nothing to the
level that the forecast predicted and
yet of course everything is shut down
here in Nashville anyway small amount of
freezing rain some slippery sidewalks
everything shuts down
if you want to know how society would
fare in an actual catastrophe like a
nuclear strike or a you know an asteroid
impact all you got to do is go to a
warmer weather climate and see how they
respond to a little bit of winter
weather
and it's a everything people panic so
that's that gives you an idea of how
well we would do which is not well at
all
right let's begin with uh this good news
from the hill
Utah has become the first state in 2023
to ban gender affirming care for minors
as Governor Spencer Cox signed a bill
Saturday to restrict their access to
puberty blockers hormones and surgical
procedures Cox said in a statement
announcing his signature that
legislation that affects minors
necessitates careful consideration and
deliberation he said the bill is not
perfect but is a more nuanced and
thoughtful approach to a terribly
divisive issue Cox said States and uh
countries are pausing gender affirming
care for new patients until additional
and improved research can be conducted
to determine the long-term consequences
of receiving this type of care lawmakers
in Alabama Arkansas Arizona and
Tennessee have all approved measures
restricting quote gender affirming care
in recent years and there are more
States as well
and this is this is in fact happening
all across the country
um Florida had previously passed a
measure to ban these procedures and here
is Ron DeSantis a couple days ago
explaining that measure a little bit
more
I mean look you have and this is sad but
this is going on you're having in our in
our society they're giving
teenagers kids
puberty blockers they're changing
they're they're doing sex change
operations and so we actually have very
you know young adults who went through
this when they were minors and they're
saying this is a huge mistake and in
fact it's not evidence-based when you
start talking about sex changes and
puberty blockers so we've worked through
our department or our medical licensing
board to say that you in the State of
Florida if you're performing those
procedures on these minors you're going
to lose your medical license here in
Florida so that is happening
[Applause]
so that's uh Ron DeSantis explaining it
and it you know the if we could say
the other leading candidate in 2024
although Ron Santos hasn't officially
announced yet uh Donald Trump unveiled
his own plan to deal with the same issue
he rolled this out yesterday uh this is
the daily wire report former president
Donald Trump on Tuesday rolled out a
sweeping proposal to protect children
from what he called left-wing gender
Insanity by barring chemical and
surgical procedures meant to change the
sex of confused minors in declaring war
on radical gender Theory Trump blasted
the blind administration's cruel
policies on so-called gender affirming
care and vowed to stop federal agencies
from promoting such policies
um
he said quote left-wing gender Insanity
being pushed on our children is an act
of child abuse
um while he said this while launching
his third bid for the nation's highest
office last November and so far the only
major Republican to have declared his
candidate 2024. the announcement comes
as radical gender ideology has come a
hot button issue with the daily wire at
the Forefront of the conversation so
that's uh so we got the santus Trump we
have all these states and then obviously
Tennessee is another one and here is a
very
disapproving report from NewsChannel 5
here in Nashville
so as a controversial bill that would
affect youth considering gender
affirming care moved toward becoming
Tennessee law Republicans are sponsoring
a bill that would ban gender affirming
surgeries for children in the state of
Tennessee Tennessee lawmakers made their
way into the discourse of gender
affirming care and minors in September
after a conservative blogger that's me a
blogger apparently I haven't
written in anything that could be called
a Blog for I don't know uh seven or
eight years but that's all right uh
questioned whether Vanderbilt University
Medical Center should provide gender
affirming care to patients Matt Walsh a
daily wire conservative commentator who
questions the legitimacy of lgbtq Rights
said he considered the care to be that
of castration and mutilation of minors
and adults
I mean the writing here on top of
everything else is tremendously bad Matt
Walsh a daily wire conservative
commentator who questions the legitimacy
of lgbtq Rights said he considered the
care to be that of castration and
mutilation of minors and adults
that's the way that that's the tortured
phrasing they're forced to use uh it in
defense of what they call gender
quote-unquote gender affirming care it's
not that I consider this quote care to
be castration mutilation it's that by
definition
that is what these
procedures do that's what the procedures
are
that's that is a a definitional thing
a standing room crowd inside the
committee room in the Cordell hall
building reached capacity before
NewsChannel 5 could even get our camera
inside Republicans invited Chloe Cole to
justify she's an 18 year old from
California at age 13 began gender
affirming care only to decide that she
didn't want to continue down that path
she spoke about why lawmakers should
pass House Bill one
and so this bill is uh making its way
through uh the process of becoming a law
and I have absolutely no doubt that it
that it will
will be law uh in short order
so we got all these things going on you
know States across the country Banning
the mutilation of kids
uh Ron DeSantis coming out strongly
against it uh Donald Trump coming out
strongly against it
and you have to keep in mind that just a
few years ago
there was no political will or momentum
to ban this Butchery at all I mean
nobody was even talking about it
there was we we had a republican White
House and Congress for two years and
they never made any attempt to do
anything about any of this they never
they never talked about it they never
brought it up
and now
and now it has become
[Music]
an issue and it's one that conservatives
are for the most part United on
and this is something that
we and I say when I say we I mean the
the anti-gender ideology movement this
is something that we made happen
this is a it's a major success story for
conservatives and the anti-gender
ideology movement
most importantly it's a successful
success success story for the kids who
are now going to be protected from this
mutilation
but it's also worth noting that um you
know I'm not sure there is any other
example that I can think of
where conservatives
mobilized and so quickly converted that
mobilization into not only cultural
change but policy changes as well
where this went from something that
wasn't even discussed a few years ago
to now
States across country Banning it
presidential candidates coming out
against it
hmm I mean it's worth paying attention
to
what we did here and how we did it
because this this should be the model
moving forward on every issue
and on top of that too I think I think
that the success goes farther than that
because we've also made it
um
not only popular and common now for
people to come out against
castrating and mutilating kids we've
also made it popular and common to
question the fundamental claims of
transgenderism quote unquote as a
concept
now it's still not popular on the left
obviously but I think normal people are
are waking up and feeling bold enough to
speak out now as I've said plenty of
times we were shooting what is a woman
and we did our uh man on the street
interviews
all across the country in many different
states and talk to lots of different
people
what we found and we were filming this
you know you started filming a year and
a half ago or so
um it was very very difficult to find
anyone
who
was willing to be skeptical about
transgenderism about any any part of it
um who was skeptical or was at least was
willing to express that skepticism on a
cam on camera
that was a year and a half ago now I'm
thinking that if we did it again to be a
very different story I think we'd have
no difficulty
finding people that would stand in front
of the camera and say no man's a man a
woman's a woman
get your hands off these kids don't do
this to kids
okay you can identify you can say you
identify as whatever you want but that
doesn't mean that you are that thing I
think it wouldn't be that hard to find
people willing to say that
a year and a half ago it was
so
I think this is a
very important lessons that we should
learn here
from a daily wire U.S Surgeon General
Vivek Murphy Murphy that is beliefs
children 13 years old are too young to
join social media platforms citing kids
are still developing their identity
quote unquote and such engagement can
create a distorted sense of themselves
Murthy who has served as Surgeon General
under the Obama and the byte
administrations signaled the warning and
interview with CNN noting adolescents
should only be allowed to access the
platforms until they are 16 years old at
the earliest
Martha said it's a time early
adolescence where kids are developing
their identity their sense of self it's
a time where it's really important for
us to be thoughtful about what's going
into how they think about their own
self-worth and their relationships and
the skewed and often distorted
environment of social media often does a
disservice to many of those children
now
this is obviously correct on every point
um
I mean the idea that children at 13 or
younger would be old enough
to engage with the entire world on a
platform because that's what social
media is you're you are saying to a
child well here you go engage with the
whole world all at once
the idea that they're old enough for
that at 13 or younger or even older is
it's Madness I mean it's truly crazy
why aren't children old enough for that
not only old enough by the way to to
engage to engage with the whole world
but also to
see and be exposed to and consume
whatever content anyone in the world
wants to post to that same platform
I mean when you put your kid on social
media
what you're saying is okay child you are
old enough to see anything that anyone
happens to want to post
that's what you're saying
which again is crazy
why aren't they old enough well because
their minds are still developing as the
Surgeon General points out they can't
make informed choices about things they
can't discern between what is true and
what is not what is harmful what is not
they're impulsive they're gullible
they're they're innocent they're
ignorant
lots of adults are all these things
except for Innocent but the rest of the
you know describes a lot of adults in
this uh in this Society the difference
is that kids have an excuse to be all of
those things
so yeah keep keep kids on social media
as I've been saying forever
and 16 is also too young by the way
there is
there's no benefit
that's another way of thinking about
these these sorts of things
anytime you're allowing your kid to do
something
you should think to yourself well what
what do they gained from this like
what's the benefit
what is the win here okay even for 16.
so your 16 year old daughter is on
Instagram and Tick Tock and all the rest
of it like what's the win for her how
does she win being on this platform
I know how she loses
we all know how she loses but what's the
win so we know what the risks are and
the risks are enormous
what are the benefits I mean it makes
sense that you know kids
have to learn how to take risks in a in
a you know in a thoughtful and
controlled environment
um as parents we have to be willing to
take risks
you know we have to be willing to in
some circumstances do things where
there's a possibility that things go
wrong
anytime you let your kid run around
outside and and play in the yard I mean
they could trip and fall and break an
ankle and there are things that could go
wrong but you allow that in a controlled
environment because the benefits are
well they get fresh air they get
exercise they get to you know have a
normal joyful childhood
and the only other option is that you
keep keep them locked inside all all
their whole childhood and we can't allow
that
but what what are the benefits of being
on social media when you're 16.
they really don't exist
so you know we can agree on most of that
apparently and I'm glad that we do
but then I can't help but point out as
many others have already pointed out
that uh the Surgeon General and the bite
Administration generally
they say that kids are 13 are too young
for social media yet yet they also say
that these are the same kids who are old
enough to change their gender
think about the the reasoning that he
gave
he didn't just point out that their
minds are developing he said that
they're that their uh their identities
are still developing they're you know
their sense of themselves
is is still developing
and
yet these are kids that can change their
gender
at their team
okay so a 12 year old
we all agree
doesn't have the mental capacity doesn't
have the psychological emotional
maturity
um doesn't have the powers of
discernment necessary to use tick tock
and yet that same child does have all
those things in in in ample quality
quantity
uh
if he declares that you know that
although he's a was born a boy he's
actually a girl
this is completely incoherent
all right
this is a video that's gone viral today
Matt Gates proposed that members of the
House Judiciary Committee should say the
Pledge of Allegiance before every
Judiciary Committee meeting and he
actually proposed this back in 2021 but
they didn't have the change they didn't
have the power then to actually
Institute this change and now they have
instituted it but Jerry Nadler um also
known affectionately as the penguin
opposed the measure and this little
exchange here has gone viral let's watch
it
in our Pledge of Allegiance is a
national symbol of Pride and unity and
it was a great honor to be able to
invite one of my constituents this
morning to offer the Pledge of
Allegiance and so my amendment gives the
committee the opportunity to begin each
of its meetings with the Pledge of
Allegiance it gives our members the
ability to invite inspirational
constituents to be able to share and
lead in The Pledge of Allegiance I
offered this amendment to the Judiciary
rules two years ago and it was defeated
and I'm very optimistic that we'll have
a different outcome today that's the
amendment Mr chairman thank the
gentleman for his Amendment support the
amendment is anyone seek recognition
gentleman from New York ranking member
now I would oppose it simply on the
grounds that as members know we pledge
allegiance every day on the floor and I
don't know why we have we should pledge
allegiance twice in the same day to show
how patriotic we are
I
kind of agree with the Penguin on this
one I'm not kind of actually I really I
really do I don't think I've ever agreed
with Nadler
on anything but on this one I agree
and I know that yeah like I said it's
gone viral on social media and there are
conservatives on Twitter that are
pretending to be outraged by it or
whatever but it's all performance I mean
they they already say the Pledge to
start the day you know the house members
say the Pledge to start the day already
there's no reason to say it again except
as empty performance you're doing it for
the cameras
it's the only reason you're doing it
um and I'd say the last thing that we
need from Congress is more performance
that's not what we need
okay it does it doesn't move the ball
down the field
and this is the kind of thing you know
it
when I first heard about this and I saw
the video
I had that reaction yeah yeah I kind of
agree with penguin honestly they don't
need to say it a second time like what
you said it once
and for most of them even once it
doesn't mean anything
okay either they are loyal to the flag
into our country or they aren't
and they could say the Pledge a million
times it's not going to make them any
more loyal so either it's either what
they're saying is true or not it doesn't
become any more true with repetition
that was my first reaction that you know
I kind of agree with who cares but then
there's more thought about it it's just
it just annoys me because this is this
is exactly the kind of
Boomer bait red meat pageantry that we
always get from Republicans the only
reason that this exists
is so that we could have that moment
where some democrat says yeah we don't
really need to do this and then it can
end up on Fox News this is a Fox News
segment okay this is this is this is
tailor-made for Fox and Friends for a
fox and friends segments the only reason
it exists it's not because the
Republicans in the Judiciary Committee
are so patriotic and they love the
country so much they just can't contain
themselves they want to say the Pledge
every five minutes they love the country
so much does anyone really believe that
it's like obviously that's the only
reason just showing off for the cameras
and also putting Democrats in a position
where they would say no so you can then
go Democrats aren't patriotic uh you
know and and by the way like political
gamesmanship like that where you're
trying to paint the other your
opposition as the bad guy I'm fine with
that that doesn't make me squeamish
but this is just for
especially lame I think and when you're
using the pledge and the flag to do it
it makes it a little bit uh
the item
irritating
all right and all the more irritating
because you're forcing you are forcing
me
to agree with and defend
Jerry The Penguin Nadler and I yeah I
resent that
right what else we got here um
so this is what story has been going on
for the last well for for months now but
really ramping up for the last few days
this is a story from a few days ago
CNN says former president Donald Trump
took aim at Ron DeSantis Saturday
claiming the Florida governor and his
team are trying to rewrite history
regarding their covid-19 pandemic
response and called the potential
presidential run by his GOP rival very
disloyal Trump told reporters while the
board is playing
the Republican Governors that did not
close their states Florida was closed
for a long time they're trying to
rewrite history he added
um
and
there are actually several examples of
this Trump has been going after DeSantis
on the lockdowns for several days he's
mentioned it a few times prior to this
but over the last few days this has been
the attack that he's decided to launch
on uh
on DeSantis he he tweeted wait and
tweeted he sent this out on his truth
social app a few days ago he said
the fake news media was good yesterday
and their coverage of my stops in New
Hampshire and South Carolina other than
the globalist Street Journal which is
rarely accurate or good they said the
the day was really amazing
um the enthusiasm to make America great
again
I don't know I don't think that there
was anyone in the news media who
described the Trump rally as really
amazing I somehow doubt that but I don't
know the enthusiasm to make America
great again has never been stronger the
revelations about Ron de sanctimonious
doing far worse than many other
Republican Governors including that he
unapologetically shut down Florida and
its beaches was interesting indeed
djt leading big okay
just a few points here and the Santa
still has not responded so Trump has
been going after DeSantis for months now
uh DeSantis has not said anything
directly in response which I think is
the right
approach
now I have heard which I think is an
interesting argument that the right the
right thing here politically is for uh
for Donald Trump to be going after
DeSantis
because he realizes he's the number one
Challenger so that's politically smart
it's also politically smart for Ron
Sanders to say nothing and so they're
both kind of doing what is politically
smart for them to do
um I agree on the latter point it's
smart for DeSantis not to respond
but be because I agree I must disagree
with the first point
like what makes DeSantis smart for not
responding is that is that is that Trump
comes off as as weak and kind of
desperate and pathetic for obsessing
over a guy that's not even talking about
him
so I don't see how it's politically
smart
for Trump to continue down this this
line of attack
when he just looks desperate I mean this
is the kind this is the advantage that
Trump has always had in the past
that his his enemies are obsessed with
him and are constantly talking about him
and it just makes them look desperate
and pathetic
we've never seen the reverse we've we've
never really seen Trump obsess over
someone who doesn't respond to him
now Trump has
attacked people in the past but they
always respond or they started by
attacking him first
this is a new one and given especially
that Rhonda Santos is in office right
now and Trump isn't so you've got Trump
ranting about the Santos DeSantis just
doing his job as Governor doing a good
job
I don't think the contrast makes Trump
look very good and then there's also the
fact that talk about rewriting history I
mean
look
Don he's he wants us to forget and I
don't think anyone actually will forget
that he shut the entire country now
okay he shot the entire 15 days to slow
the spread that turned that turned into
months and months and months that was
Trump
he handed the country over to to Dr
fauci
he could have fired him but he didn't
and in explaining why he didn't fire him
Trump has has said that that the reason
he did fire fauci is that the media
would have been really mad at him if he
did it that's his excuse
that's what he has actually said that he
couldn't have fired fauci because the
media would have complained
so instead you would hand our entire
country over to this
narcissistic psycho
um
so
taking the guy who was
very Pro lockdown
and trying to make him into the lockdown
guy while you were the lockdown
president uh yeah I don't know about
that I don't I don't it's obviously not
true but of course we know in politics
truth is sometimes irrelevant
the question is whether that whether
this narrative will resonate with him
can he convince anyone to actually buy
into this
I tend to doubt it
and not only
was Trump the guy who locked down the
country
he attacked DeSantis and Kemp for
opening their states too soon Trump when
he was in office went after DeSantis and
kempin in uh in Georgia for opening
their states he said it was Reckless and
dangerous to do it
it's not hard to like anyone can find
the tweets and the statements and the
things that he said at press conferences
it's all out there it's all documented
I'm uh
very skeptical of this approach
all right finally I uh on Monday
afternoon I appeared on Piers Morgan's
show and we talked about as we've
discussed in the show here the viral
trend of women trying to entrap men at
the gym by filming them and pretending
that the men were harassing them and I
made one point that scandalized one of
the feminists on the panel and uh let's
listen to that
I don't think you can avoid looking at
people because I'm looking up to see
what their forms like how they're
carrying certain weights are they
carrying more than me you know male or
female I don't really care I'm just I'm
quite curious about other people using a
gym am I now going to be something
appearing on Instagram influence
influences sites is some sort of perv
well it's possible and look by the way I
also I don't mean to be a victim blamer
here but but can we also say that if
you're a woman and you don't want to you
don't want men to notice you in the gym
maybe wear more than your underwear to
go work out these women whose videos
they're wearing sports bras and like hot
pants I mean how it puts your clothes on
if you don't want people to look at you
this is victim blaming yeah I'm sorry
Barbara Atwood here that uh men are
afraid of women laughing at them women
are afraid that men are going to kill
them it is not okay to say that it's a
woman's fault for wearing the wrong you
think the people looking over at people
using some equipment a gym are going to
kill them I think that taking
photographs is threatening staring at
people is photographing it are these
Instagram influencers they are video
hearing men taking photographs of them
and listening
victim victim with the Margaret Atwood
quote there
um
and and actually just so you know
uh man the the big fear that men have
when it comes to women especially women
who try to do exactly what these women
in the gym are doing
um the fear is not being laughed at the
the fear is being publicly shamed it's
being falsely accused it's having your
life and reputation destroyed
being laughed out to your face who cares
about that
the fear is reputational destruction
and that is a power that women wield
much more than men
okay an accusation from a man in our
society doesn't carry a lot of weight
but we know we've heard the the slogans
believe all women believe women and we
also know that the people that say that
you know there are plenty of women that
they don't want to believe such as the
woman that accused Joe Biden of sexual
assault but
that's the slogan anyway
so one woman says something and your
life is destroyed that is the fear for
men and it's a it's a valid fear
um and having your entire life and
reputation destroyed is a is a
major tragic event it's not simply being
laughed at
but I know that I said kind of
facetiously I don't mean to victim blame
but fine I am victim blaming okay if if
if we're talking about someone who is a
woman who is the victim she's the victim
of a man looking at her if that's the
kind of victimization we're talking
about a man looking at you if that makes
you a victim if that makes you a victim
then yes I blame you if you're walking
outside of your house in your underwear
uh yes that you you have made yourself
the victim by doing everything in your
power to attract the male gaze not just
the male gaze but anyone's gaze
because as I said when we talked about
this last week if I walked out of the
house of my underwear If any man walked
out of the house people would stare at
us
they might not stare
uh in a in a sort of pleased way but
they would still be staring
whether they're horrified and grossed
out or whatever whatever the reason for
saying they'd be staring because they'd
be thinking why look at that person in
their underwear let's just say that's a
normal human response when you walk
around in your underwear
if that makes you a victim to be the
object of someone's gaze okay if that's
the kind of victimization we're talking
about then yes you deserve the blame for
it you deserve actually 100 of the blame
for it
if you're walking around your underwear
um if you're dressed in a way that is
that is designed
to attract people's gaze
and then you get exactly what you're
what you were hoping for
yes the blame goes to you
uh without question
and there's a pretty easy solution here
which is to put on clothes and also
it does make me question you know I know
we hear from the feminists women walk
around all the time terrified that a
man's going to kill them
is that
so then you walk around your underwear
like
wearing your underwear to the gym that's
the behavior of a woman who's afraid
she's going to be killed by a man
that if you're afraid of men and
that's how you respond
now this that to me seems like the
behavior of someone who has no fears at
all that's just that someone who's
utterly oblivious and not afraid of
anything
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a sweet baby gang
sorry I have some comments here well
these are uh from two days ago so we
missed the shows today but Chrissy
Liberty says Matt forgot to mention
Pelosi having a drink in his hand when
he opened the door can't imagine if he
really feared for your life you would uh
you'd stop for a drink
well
yeah I think people were saying that he
had a cocktail in his hand and I think
it looked to me like just a glass of
water
but
it does make sense because again Pelosi
was trying to act nonchalant
and he was telling the Intruder that
yeah we're just waiting for my wife
um and uh he probably offered him a
drink you know it would be a normal
thing to do he's trying to play it off
um which which is the the smart move
especially when you're an unarmed
elderly man and a crazy Intruder breaks
into your house
your best move really your only move is
to try to de-escalate the situation and
uh you know rather than using Force to
get your way out of it you got to use
your wits um and that's what he tried to
do
Kyle Ross as Matt it's unfair to say
that that man skates so bad that he
makes you look like a professional
skater because you skate like a graceful
swan
well thank you I I didn't want to say
that about myself because it seemed
although I'm not sure that swans really
are graceful on the ice so there might
be we might need a fact check on that
um
ghost Leviathan says Matt what's your
take on cigarettes I know you have
attacked other drugs but just want to
get your take on them
you know cigarette I I don't smoke them
uh I don't think you should smoke them
I don't think it's you know I I we
talked before about how does social
media improve your life if you're a
child really how does it improve your
life if you're any age
you can ask a similar question about
cigarettes how is that going to improve
your life
um probably isn't
but so yeah what what's my opinion on
that I don't think you should smoke
cigarettes I also don't think you should
eat fast food every day right but people
do
um
however cigarettes we don't put them on
the same plane as Fentanyl and heroin
and crack and all that kind of stuff
um because
of the effect on individual that those
drugs have
where they're gonna they could they
could kill you on the spot first of all
they are certain to utterly destroy your
life immediately
you know they're going to turn you into
a zombified husk of a person cigarettes
don't do that
um and also the effect that they have on
society
like a society where lots of people
smoke cigarettes can be very functional
and we know that because that was the
society that we lived in for much of the
20th century much of the 20th century
while America was uh was was thriving
it was at the same time a time when like
everybody was smoking
now I'm not saying it's because of the
cigarettes I'm not necessarily saying we
should go back we should all start
smoking cigarettes again
um but we know that we can have a
functional Society where people smoke
can we have a functional Society
where lots and lots of people are on
these hard drugs the answer is
absolutely no
we can't even have a functional City
where a where where a sizable minority
are on these drugs
we see what they've done to the cities
so I think there's a clearly a very a
big difference here
night Warrior says no sir white people
are not to blame for the things that we
black people do
well night Warrior that is internalized
racism that is internalized white
supremacy I'm told that we're hearing
from you
Christopher says come on man I expected
better from you at least this talking
point of the 911 operator being bad at
the job is horribly dumb she obviously
knew what was going on since police were
dispatched we don't need to divert from
the main point by making light of
completely misconstrued talking points
no the 911 dispatcher tried to hang up
the phone okay she was ready to hang up
but let's not forget that when Paul
Pelosi said yes this person came into my
house and is waiting for my wife my
wife's name is Nancy Pelosi they're here
waiting for my wife and they say
everything's fine but I don't think so
it was at that moment that dispatcher
said but all right talk to you later
hey give us a ring back if there's any
problems
so no I think we can say that she did a
terrible job and in fact Matthew W uh no
relation agrees says Matt that 911
dispatcher did a terrible job and it's
honestly embarrassing I was a dispatcher
for seven years and one thing drilled
into into you is listening for clues
that lead you to believe that the caller
is calling Under duress you must listen
carefully to your callers especially
when things don't make sense you're
supposed to ask yes or no questions to
give them options that might be
transparent to someone uh next to them
for example is someone there say
pepperoni for yes and cheese for no for
example if they call call you to ask for
a pizza dispatchers need to be able to
adapt and use critical thinking
well okay so there's the former 91
dispatcher who agrees with me so I feel
pretty good about that and that was my
other problem with the non-one
dispatcher in the Pelosi call Is Not
only was she like trying to get off the
phone almost she was annoyed she wanted
to get back to doing whatever she was
doing
but
she was also asking questions that were
not yes or no questions she was asking
questions that forced Paul Pelosi to say
things out loud that would reveal that
he was talking to a 911 operator
so
not a great job all around
as you've heard we've been running a
massive 40 off sale for annual
memberships and it's uh this Friday that
It Ends don't miss the chance to
celebrate one of the greatest moments in
Daily wire history with one of the
greatest offers that's 40 off annual
memberships with code do not comply the
deal ends on Friday so you don't want to
wait one year ago we sued the government
over its tyrannical vaccine mandate and
we won you can celebrate this Victory
with us by joining the winning team when
you join you get access to the best
content one of the fastest growing
libraries and again you're on the team
with us making changes in the culture
we're adding a ton of new content this
year with kids uh content more movies
more shows hard hitting documentaries
and more remember this is your last
chance to get 40 off your your new
annual membership at dailywire.com
subscribe with code do not comply the
sale ends this Friday so head to
dailywire.com subscribe lock in your
discount now to enjoy all of our great
releases coming soon now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation day we turn
to New Jersey a state that is always
perpetually canceled simply for existing
but you know the state's general
crappiness and the fact that the whole
place smells like a poorly maintained
Burger King restroom is incidental um
for our discussion today new jersey.com
has a story about a former public school
teacher now suing the school that she
says drove her to quit after shaming her
for having emotional breakdowns in the
classroom a lot going on here let's
start at the top says a former teacher
in the South Orange Maplewood school
district has filed a lawsuit claiming
that she was forced to resign after
transfer to teach special education
without an aide caused her to have
crying spells in the classroom Sarah
Barlow 34 of West Orange said in court
papers that she was teaching
kindergarten at South Mountain
Elementary school during the 2020-2021
school year when she was abruptly
transferred to the district's Annex
school to teach a different class Barlow
was asked to teach a classroom that
included special education students yet
she was not provided any special
education teachers or paraprofessionals
to assist her according to the suit
filed December 22nd prior to a trans as
for Barlow had disagreements with school
principal Kevin Mason over the handling
of two troubled students according to
the suit
all right well so far it seems as though
Miss Barlow has legitimate reasons to be
frustrated she was pulled out of her
class thrown into a more difficult
situation without proper supporter
resources assuming of course that her
version of events is correct and I have
no reason to doubt that it is after all
it all sounds
haphazard inefficient
self-defeating
which is exactly what we've come to
expect from the public school system and
if this is where the story ended then
she would have my sympathy but
unfortunately it keeps going and my
sympathy quickly evaporates continuing
this situation caused Miss Barlow a
significant amount of emotional distress
and exacerbated her anxiety a condition
she has suffered with since her teenage
years the suit States on October 24th
Mason sent Barlow a letter admonishing
her for exhibiting signs of anxiety and
stress in the classroom the suit said
Barlow alleges that her symptoms were
caused by not having an aid and by
Mason's alleged mistreatment in this
letter Mason stated that Miss Barlow's
crying spells were unprofessional and
stated that in corrective action would
be forthcoming the lawsuit says that
Barlow's therapist then placed her on a
six-week medical leave due to the Stress
and Anxiety that she was experiencing at
work
okay so she broke down in tears in front
of our students multiple times and then
took a six week vacation to work on her
feelings
sorry it wasn't a vacation it was
medical leave because in our insane
culture we use the same language to
describe a woman taking a break from her
work because she was anxious
as we do to describe a woman taking a
break from work because you know she
needs a heart transplant
but it gets better listen uh it says
quote unfortunately due to the
district's failure to address her
complaints of unlawful behavior and
complete disregard for her disability
and mental health Miss Barlow was forced
to resign from a position on November
1st 2022 the suit States the lawsuit
says that Barlow's anxiety which
requires medical treatment is a
recognized disability under the New
Jersey law against discrimination in
addition Administration administrators
in the South Orange Maplewood School
District failed to accommodate Barlow's
disability disciplined her for her
symptoms and failed to include her in
the discussions about reasonable
classroom accommodations the suit says
okay
so to use a phrase that I hate
um there's a lot to unpack here first of
all you know I do hold men to a higher
standard of stoicism
than I hold women to
um as as as men we should be expected
even more to Bear difficulty and
hardship without complaint
this capacity is one of the things that
makes a man valuable to his family and
his community it's what makes a man a
man
and it's why men who cannot carry their
burdens with silent dignity are so
incredibly useless and such a strain on
everybody around them
and also really unappealing to women
because it's the last thing that they
want
now women are more expressive more
emotive more empathetic by nature which
is why we have we have and should have
greater tolerance for their emotional
displays but that tolerance only goes so
far because whether you're a man or a
woman
if you're in a position of leadership
especially if that leadership position
involves caring for and educating
children
you need to be able to handle stress and
frustration and setback without making
it everyone else's problem
women have a greater compulsion to share
their feelings with those around them
which is usually fine if they're sharing
their feelings with their husbands or
their friends or their family or trusted
confidant
but the children in your classroom are
none of those things
let's hope
they are not going to school in order to
be sounding boards for your frustrations
or to validate your feelings
your responsibility is to provide them
an education one that is unburdened by
your emotional baggage
if you can't do that or you won't do it
then you shouldn't be teaching
I mean I don't care what you've been
through in your life I don't care how
difficult your life is or has been
sometimes in life it is it is your
responsibility to suppress your feelings
the feelings you have about those
difficulties and carry on like nothing
is wrong
I know that's a shocking thing to hear
these days people here but yeah there
are plenty of times in life where no
matter what you're going through it is
your responsibility to deal with it and
shut up and do your job
it's what's expected of you
you know the doctor who's performing
brain surgery on you he might be having
a bad day also
but you'd be very concerned if he came
into the room right before they put you
under sobbing and crying and complaining
about his anxiety disorder
and that's because in his capacity as
brain surgeon you expect him to do his
duty and to subordinate his feelings
whatever he's going through you expect
him to just deal with it and get the job
done like a professional
you would expect that of your heart
surgeon your brain surgeon your your
airplane pilot
um really anyone else who's performing a
job that you need done
you would be annoyed if you ordered a
pizza and it came to your house late and
the reason it came late is because the
the pizza delivery guy is having a
really bad day and and you know
struggling with his feelings that would
annoy you and it should
because you're you're here to do a job
and your job is to bring me the pizza
and in that same way you know we expect
you to do your job as well
and again if you can't do it there's
always the other option which is to
which is to not if you really can't if
you can't do the job then don't do the
job leave the job
if you're there people expect you to do
it it's that simple
second Point anxiety is not a disability
it is not a medical condition no matter
how often this claim is made no matter
what the psychiatrists say no matter the
billions of dollars the pharmaceutical
companies are able to make off of it
anxiety is not a disease it is rather
just one of the tolls we all must pay
for the privilege of being human
there's nothing strange or unique about
the person who experiences anxiety
there would be something quite strange
about the human the human being who did
not experience it but no such human
exists or has ever existed
of course the medical industry will
claim that what I'm talking about you
know when I say everyone experiences
anxiety what the medical industry says
is that that's just regular anxiety
that's average anxiety that's that's
anxiety in its normal amount
but when anxiety reaches beyond that
threshold that's when it magically
becomes an illness as medically valid as
diabetes or Parkinson's or the flu
who decides what qualifies as normal
anxiety who determines where the
threshold is who gets to declare what
what amount of anxiety we're supposed to
have
well coincidentally enough the people
who have drugs to sell us they get to
decide
and they're the only ones who can decide
by the way indeed if you as a human
being
dare to speak about anxiety which is the
most ubiquitous of all human experiences
and if you dare to speak about it as
someone who is not selling anything
someone who doesn't stand to profit off
of your position on the subject that
somehow makes you less reliable
the message is clear when it comes to
questions of supposed mental illnesses
the only trustworthy people are the
people who are financially incentivized
to come up with certain answers
this is all nonsense of course questions
about the nature of anxiety and what we
should do with anxiety and how much
anxiety a healthy person should
experience
these are philosophical questions These
Are Spiritual questions
they're questions that defy simple
medical analysis
questions that cannot be reduced down to
formulas or solved merely with
prescription medication
and the problem is that the spiritual
authorities the priests and philosophers
of our day are the people who put the
title doctor in front of their names we
have long since given them authority
over not only strictly scientific and
medical questions but deeper questions
about the very purpose and nature of the
human person and about the meaning of
life and how life is supposed to be
lived and how people are supposed to
feel and and and and all of that
we've done this partly because we've
been duped and we do this partly because
we prefer the fiction that these people
are selling us
because it lets us off the hook
it allows us to claim that we have no
control over our emotions
we can't be blamed for how we behave
and now it even allows us to claim
disability and take six weeks of medical
leave because we're feeling stressed out
that's what Miss Sarah Barlow is up to
and it's why she is today finally
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
show as we move over to the members
block if uh you want to become a member
you can do that now by using Code wall
should check out for two months free on
all annual plans hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]